critics say this is the greatest game of
all time
I say nerds it [ __ ] hurts playing
this what the [ __ ]
what what the actual hate you Sonic they
ruined my life oh my god I have to do
everything again oh [ __ ] if I die now
it's ready today we're gonna play sanic
zero six it's a best game ever any Sonic
game is the best game ever and if you
say no then you're [ __ ] wrong take it
back so we have this intro I don't know
why I don't know why the [ __ ] this is
here it's the most Awkward [ __ ] ever I
think I think the entire body I went
into this for the who the [ __ ] are you
Sonic game box Isis sonic thing the
Hedgehog Sonic game oh there it is
there's a plot trip everyone knows a new
way great I have to watch this can't
click away
that's a pretty snazzy performance there
[Music]
that's a pretty snazzy performance Kent
I can't watch this anymore I can't there
must be some way to skip it
no oh come on my controller haven't been
working this whole time that's why I
couldn't scan oh look it's morning yay
I'm friend and city
best game first oh god what that [ __ ]
was that
what just happened what are you doing in
the pool I'd be trapped forever in the
pool this is my new favorite game
already I love it love it love it
[Music]
come on I gotta slow the ps3 is there's
so much to explore where should we go
never mind we can't go here oh cool I
can grind yeah gotta appreciate the
effort tails does Peggy tells call
awesome cool that's that's great
there's two san e's what's better than
when san e to sanics tails no tails
oh wait the barrel had lemons
[Music]
where the [ __ ] was ulemas tails killed
himself because he's scared of lemons
so he's tails forever dead now all right
no I can deal with that
yeah I'll test your shoes give me your
shoes
Oh God what was that you weren't in a
hurry a second ago
what are you drowned there there we go
I'm fine [ __ ] fine what was that
set the old fence stop stop
you can't make me look at those [ __ ]
dolphins
those are the most [ __ ]
realistic dolphins I ever seen in my
left only sanic oh hey how's it going
I know much just just chillin just
chillin Sonic that I'm Sonic the
Hedgehog how how's it going how's
everyone doing sanic the Hedgehog here
no big deal just [ __ ] famous and [ __ ]
am i running back hey hey we're here how
about that ah I'm fine I'm going the
[ __ ] [ __ ] drown out of everything I
swear to god sunny
gotta go fast I guess going so fast yeah
gotta go Sonique oh you're right and
same a pass sonic walks sonic likes to
stroll too you know
well I'm by these enemies are posting
such a threat oh I'm so happy
let's ask or D give me the D [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] I deserve the D alright then
well [ __ ] everything [ __ ] you sonic used
to be cool maybe like for sanic if you
love sanic just as I as much as I love
sanic and we will sanic in the next
episode sanic sanic fist for scenic